okay so i need
a definitive answer on something
there's no wiggle room you guys say
right now
are we ever going to see you do the dunk
contest
[Music]
are you enjoying l.a yeah it's smooth
i'm ready to get back home though yeah
it's funny seeing you in la because
you're not like a big city scenic mixy
person i like being in the cut at the
crib yeah in my own bed
so then how do you handle like here
everyone's like where are we at tonight
where the bottles what we doing like how
do you kind of handle that when you know
it's not really your comfort zone uh
stay at the crib my peoples yeah
lately we just been playing madden
against each other so
that really just kept us out of the mix
yeah from being outside when you play
what team do you play with
uh the cardinals
why
d-hop
okay are y'all friends yeah that's my
guy south carolina
of course okay are you good at madden
gonna let my fam out
answer that question
i mean i don't really know if that means
yes or no i'm like 15 and one right now
uh so if anybody wants smoking mad and
just hit me up
do you play anyone in the league nah i
just started playing when we got here
really
i kind of i rock with it a little bit
now yeah i'm like so you're a weekend
and you're 15 and one yeah i'm nice like
that cause i don't think you
are a gamer or were a gamer right no i
mean i played but not as much i played
call of duty yeah but
like i don't play the game like every
day probably
two three times a week if that yeah and
it's just caught on yeah yeah
you gotta run around with baby girl man
yeah so you don't really have time to
i'm sure you miss her being here yeah
that's why i'm ready to go yeah but i
love like you facetime her all the time
yeah yeah i'm sure she'll facetime me i
was gonna say she probably knows how to
work it yeah she's not to hang up uh
everything put me on pause and say she
want to watch tick-tock
oh she's a tick-tocker yeah what it was
just like the dance so she heard any
music she gonna dance that's really
sometimes she'll dance without music she
just i guess played a song in my head
just yeah
well you dance with that music sometimes
yeah
she definitely gets that from you i
would say just be vibing you know good
energy
well so i'm like everybody knows you are
my favorite you're my favorite for a
multitude of reasons one because i
interviewed you like right before you
got drafted and you still
act the exact same
uh two because i love your dad
that's actually my favorite person on
earth you you're like number two
um but a huge reason why is you are like
one of the most supportive people i
think not even just in the league but
just in general i think especially with
women especially with black women i
think when people have just kind of gone
through hard times you always very
publicly support you've done it with me
you've done it maria taylor you've done
it with shikari you've done reno
miyosaka wnba players
where does that come from for you
because i don't think
a lot of the guys are like that or a lot
of guys in general i can say it's just
how i was raised you know to you know
just treat everybody you know how i want
to be treated um i'm a very you know
caring person you know full of love so
um i just you know
spread love uh positive energy
it's pretty much me yeah but you do
realize like how much that probably
means to the people that you are doing
it for yeah uh
100
um
and now you know i have a you know i
feel like a
bigger voice
um so i feel like you know it
eventually you know they will see it and
you know more people will you know start
doing the same so
what do you think about the way it feels
like everyone was like so team shakar
rooting for shikari and then she did the
race and it was like everybody just kind
of turned on her i mean what was that
like for you to see online i feel like
that's just life that's how it is like
when you up you know everybody want to
you know clap be your friend you know
but as soon as you know some little
thing like her just losing a race they
all just flipped on it
that's just how it is i feel like if she
raced again
the next day and would have won they
would have been
back on you know uh she's the greatest
it's just it's life um
i'm you know i like how she you know
dealt with it but
um she's gotta you know come back and
redeem herself the thing that was so
puzzling to me about that whole thing is
everyone's like
she's too cocky
like well no she just thought she was
gonna win yeah i feel like she's not
cocky i just feel like she's just got a
lot of confidence in herself i feel like
it's the same with me like i'm not cocky
at all very humble but i'm confident too
so yeah if i feel like you know i'm the
best you know i'm gonna say that so yeah
i feel like that's just what she was
doing one thing i always remember um
when michael jordan did the last dance
everybody's watching it over the
pandemic
he was talking about a player i can't
remember who but he was like i respect
this player because
he was still talking trash while he was
losing like he stayed consistent he
stayed the same with it
and i actually think it's like a sign of
strength and a sign of like really
knowing who you are that even at the end
of the race she was like i'm gonna come
back
it's like people want to see somebody be
defeated when they are defeated yeah and
i don't really know what
like people get from that especially
online i don't either honestly yeah
you know i'm with that you know staying
consistent no matter if you're winning
or losing um
so back to saying like i like how she
dealt with it like right after she was
like you know i'll be back like just got
to put in my work yeah just simple as
that totally now you are someone who
loves to engage on twitter
you will talk to the fans i think at one
point at post game interview you were
like that was for you who said we
weren't going to win this so tell tell
me that story and what happened with
that tweet
um it's pretty much just you know it'd
be a lot of talking i'll be seeing
um
it really be my mom she'd be trying to
you know get me off of twitter all the
time like don't even
don't even go on twitter don't look at
your phone like that and
you know i was just looking and i just
you know i'll be seeing people talking
all the time before games after games
and i normally don't say too much you
know before
uh sometimes i want to but
you know i'll be like nah we got to lock
in on the game like you know just let
the win you know do the talking or
whatever so then after the fact if we
win now
i can say whatever i want yeah so just
like you know they they go in there and
talk i'm gonna talk back so if anybody
at me
better be prepared for a reply but be
prepared for that post game interview
i'm calling out your at name yeah so get
ready and i'll put all my fans i'm gonna
make sure they get into all your
mentions replies
everything
dm's they'll make sure they all dm all
of it i love it i know okay so for me i
remember when i like first started in my
career
to be completely honest i like really
cared about social media like i really
cared about what someone was tweeting
about me or commenting you reach a point
where like you stop caring right but
i think that when there's so many people
always saying things about you it's hard
to completely block it off are there
times that it does somewhat get to you
are you completely used to it at this
point i feel
like sometimes you know like it it gets
under my skin so that's you know when i
say something
um
but most of the time you know i just be
cool like it's hard to not see
everything like even on my twitter
if i scroll for a minute it'll have like
john marant right there and then it just
show all the tweets that got my name in
it so like oh okay i don't know how to
get away from that so like i may
eventually you know see the tweet or
whatever but
like you know i really don't care i feel
like you know now social media is just
brainwashing people like
people living lives you know they're not
living in real life yeah they just go on
there just to you know say something
negative just to you know get attention
so
and like why not be nice
and like everyone should just be nice to
everyone all the time like what do you
get out of being mean to somebody online
like i just i don't understand like what
would be the point of making a comment
that
is at least neutral right like it's okay
to say okay i don't think you had a
great game that's fine yeah but like i
just think sometimes people tend to take
it to another level that it just like
doesn't really really have to go you see
some players get you know death threats
and all this stuff like nah that's too
far no totally absolutely i mean that's
that's actually life like there's no
place in the world where like things
don't have real consequences except for
online yeah um and so i just think at
some point there is going to be this
awakening for people that decide that's
what they what they want to do online
they behind the phone so they feel like
they can say whatever yeah i doubt most
of them say it in person
no like 100 percent
nobody would see it in person
yeah i mean so speaking of you know just
absolutely unacceptable things i know
obviously in utah your family was
unfortunately subject to like a terrible
racist incident there i know that your
dad has spoke on it but i just want to
know for you what was that like and what
was the timeline from when you like
realized what happened because obviously
you were playing a game a great game by
the way that um kind of ended up being
marred by by this happening um
i feel like you know it was tougher for
me um you know like i every game you
know i know my my people sitting at no
matter if we hold my way like
i ask you know where they sitting at
before the game so you know i can look
sometimes my mom will you know wave and
just be like you know let's go
my pops are normally courtside but you
know we was away i put them all in you
know the same section for that reason
you know hearing about you know how utah
fans were
and i mean i was i think it was second
half you know i was
uh
scoring like i think i scored like back
to back and it was a time out
and like i just went to look up and i
just see like my whole family standing
up and then i knew
at that point it was you know something
so like i'm like
trying to look back but i'm like bro i
gotta lock into the game but
my loyalty like
i felt like if anything had to happen i
would have probably end up in the
bleachers so i was just trying to you
know just tell like our security like
just tell them just you know stop and
chill but at that time i didn't know
what was going on
so i mean it was i felt like you know my
peoples was like
like josh easy for you to say to calm
down but you don't know what's going
going on or whatever and then they
finally told me after and then i was
like
well i wish i told y'all to just you
know go ahead and handle your business
it's funny because that's what everyone
says they're like listen arena's the
point where disrespect is disrespectful
yeah yeah and like me like my whole
family like you know they're laughing
joke like we all good people like even
if y'all like we met you for five
minutes like you know we gonna treat you
like
you know
we knew you for a while laughing and
joking and
if you see any of my family you know get
to that point obviously they fed up so
yeah it feels like lucky luckily there
has been you know a crackdown on what is
going to be acceptable for nba fans
but why do you think fans even feel like
they could have acted that way to begin
with
i honestly don't know i feel like you
know my fam like you know laughing and
joking obviously but
they just as confidence uh confident in
me as i am so i'm pretty sure it was
like
oh he go like he waking up and they
probably you know just start getting mad
because we was coming back no he was big
waking up i think there was 47 points in
that game
so i i mean honestly i don't know i just
feel like you know they feel like they
can
you know get away with a lot of stuff
and most of the time if it's a you know
incident where
it's a fan and a player normally
the player you know the one that get
punished get all the attention so
i felt like you know they just felt like
they would have you know got away with
it utah definitely uh when we came back
you know showed us you know a lot of
love so
uh we appreciate that yeah there was a
really beautiful moment between your dad
and donovan yeah um i know donovan very
publicly on twitter was like this is
wrong this is unacceptable like we're
all humans we're just trying to play
this game so it's really nice to see
your dad say listen you're great i'm
happy you did that i'm rooting for y'all
what was kind of the inception of that
moment and did you get to talk to
donovan and your family get to talk to
him yeah i talked to a couple of players
on their team um even when they came to
us for game three me like on my pre-game
uh shooting a lot of players you know
came up to me and apologized you know
for what happened so i like i
appreciated that and um
my parents obviously wasn't at the you
know pre-game stuff so that was really
like the first time you know they you
know came in contact you know with a
player and
uh donovan you know
sent me a
personal message to you know me and my
family and then was able to you know
talk to my dad and like i said like
we show everybody love you know we treat
everybody the same and that's just you
know the type of people we are you know
my dad's saying you know
even though like we lost he hoped they
you know go all the way and you know win
it just for you know what they've been
doing so yeah no i love that video it's
so good it's so good okay so i need
a definitive answer on something
there's no wiggle room you guys say
right now
are we ever going to see you do the dunk
contest
i don't think so really i don't think so
now okay so we've had conversations
about the done contest and i know your
biggest thing is about the judging of
the dun contest
so
what would it take for you to be like
okay you know what i i will do this
a million dollars
best nun gets a meal
they give me a meal you know
and i
i get a dunk contest
so until then
i'll be watching and just you know
sending my tweets out for you know
judging and stuff but i feel like now
you know
you just see
so many like crazy dunks in game that
when the dunk contests come you you just
you know you don't appreciate the dunk
as much and not too many people can do
the dunks you know guys are doing in
that dunk contest so i feel like if you
look at it that way it'll be a lot of
more
you know 50s yeah
at what point did you change your mind
though because there was a time you were
like done contest is great i love to do
it one day then i just think you were
kind of watching you're like all right
maybe not like when did that shift
happen
the judge like the past you know two
years i was like nah how would you judge
it if you got to figure if you decided
how they were judged who judged all that
stuff tell me what your format would be
for that i probably would still do you
know like the you know former players uh
the judge but
i just feel like you know you just got
to look at it as
how many people can actually do this
dump or like how difficult was it to you
know do this dump because even though
like you have somebody you know
made that don't look easy it's not like
it's times where like i'd be in the gym
you know trying some of the dunks and be
like bro like it took me 10 times just
like
and they go make it on the first time so
i feel like they look at it as now that
was too easy for him but not looking at
the actual dunks so they'll be like all
right this is an eight when it should be
a 10 you know
like they actually just made it look
easier and that's why they should get
the 10. that's exactly why especially
if you're doing uh between the legs
backwards like
same foot same hand between like
you don't see people doing that all the
time so mm-hmm
if you did the dunk contest in this
fictional world um tell me three players
that you think would give you like
the best run for your money
like the best competition for you in
that dunk contest zach levine
uh aaron gordon
and i'm kind of in a toss-up between uh
derek jones jr and uh
zion
okay yeah that would be a fun one yeah
hey maybe one day every one day they fix
the judging and they get the competition
we can make this work mba we can do it
um you've obviously had a lot of great
in-game dunks
who do you want to dunk on that you have
not dunked on yet
lebron
yeah for sure i'll probably uh
get that poster like just put it
as soon as you walk in my house
probably have it all over the wall like
you own the door just cause like it's
it's lebron like yeah
even i remember watching uh when tatum
actually don't know like i don't know
what i would have done in that moment
because like i can do a regular dunk and
i'll be screaming for about
three four seconds and be behind the
place so like if i actually like you
know like dunk home lebron like i
probably would get a
tech you just won't be able to handle it
yeah like
it's lebron like not even on like you
know big fan like i'm a fan of his game
and it's you know it's braun but like
who wouldn't want to dunk on lebron
yeah like that saying like back in the
day like who wouldn't want to dunk on
jordan like
mm-hmm
it's gonna happen you can tell your kids
but i'd be like you know i don't know
lebron or jordan right like
she probably don't know who that he is
right now but
pull up the tape yeah that's the photo
that's behind us on the wall
um tell me about kind of like
the anatomy of a dunk right like for
example how did you know
you could jump over kevin love like at
what point are you like i can make this
work i think it was like a
i think
if i remember the playwright i think
dylan was dribbling and like the ball
kicked off his foot
so like when i picked it up a lot of the
cavs player was like chasing after the
ball but like i picked it up and then
all i seen was the gold really honestly
and then i went to you know just like
all right well it's time to dunk and
then kevin love was right there so i'm
like
well it's too late to try to do
something now like i can't just
jump and then come down like nah never
mind i ain't trying to dunk so i just i
tried it yeah i ended up clearing them
but i i tried to dunk the ball too hard
and hit the back room but even your
missed dunks
i like works of art like they still look
pretty good i think i'm more known for
missing dunks than making them right now
my comments be like make a dunk or
people would be like
land on two legs
like bro do you know how hard it is to
try to do that every time like yeah i'd
be want to comment and be like
you know as other players land in the
same way i'm landing right like
i can try to control it but it don't
work every time
why do you think your dunks look so cool
though like i saw those photos that
you'd retweeted where it's two different
games but it's like the exact same
i'm like how does how does that happen
probably a
turnover i'd be thirsty on fast breaks
like uh
i don't know i turned into the fastest
player ever just run down the court
looking for the dunk like yeah
uh even though that pitcher i think it
was versus the mavs
uh i have to pull the video up but when
kyle passed it and i dunked it he was
like
dang 12 you thirsty when he was running
back and i was laughing at him but like
i just take off running and
i just try to you know kind of play like
cat and mouse like if i know i have
people you know ahead of me i like run
slow so the defense will try to you know
go to them and then i just come shooting
straight down the middle and i think
both of those dunks was like the same
play okay
just different games yeah are you for
the person that's like getting dunked in
dunked on are you a believer in okay
make the business i shouldn't get out
the way or like try to stop the dog nah
i'm gonna get out of the way
like i don't want to be in the picture
i'm six three one 175 soaking wet like
what i look like trying to jump with
somebody like that i'm just swiping just
move by the way like you got it
hopefully i just
you know tip the ball before they go up
but i didn't got dunked on a couple
times before yeah that's why
it comes for everybody i want to dunk on
people and uh i know like once i dunk on
somebody like that feeling of trying to
get the ball out fast you know i don't
want to be one of them so i'ma just
swipe sometimes i might try you know if
i if i jump before you i'm
if i can jump before you i'm gonna try
to block it but yeah if you already on
your gather step
you got it
yeah you got it continue i might just
push you up like go ahead
um i remember uh in the press conference
in the bubble after your rookie season i
asked what you will remember most about
that year
and your answer was not making the
playoffs
what will you remember the most about
this past season it's a similar answer
you know making the playoffs but you
know
not getting farther um it's just you
know just
i feel like you know we we showed you
know we we're one of the you know top
teams in this league we can play with
the top teams in this league
i feel like you know just our experience
and you know just gelling together
um
kind of played a factor in it but
obviously you know we still you know
fought throughout the series but um i
really just love like
both both years
even though like we lost
we all still had the same mindset of you
know well
we got to work so after we you know
didn't make it the first year
uh
we was like we got to lock in this
offseason and make it next year then we
did so now it's the next step which is
you know
getting farther and you know trying to
actually you know win a championship so
i feel like you know this year uh guys
been together a lot in the gym uh
together which is i feel like you know
what's good for us without chemistry and
we just gotta you know continue to
come together as one
and one thing i think every nba fan
realized about the grizzlies is y'all do
not give up yeah
like there is so much fight and y'all
seen like y'all are never dead it's like
you cannot even take your foot off the
gas a little bit because y'all will come
back i mean where does that come from
for you guys i just feel like we have
the right pieces around us i feel like
you know we all kind of the same you
know with that
uh underdog mindset you know never
satisfied like
it's times like we can win a game and
you know we'll still be you know
frustrated you know with how we played
because we know
all right this game wasn't even supposed
to be that close yeah we just never
satisfied we always want to get better
and that's just our mentality to go out
there and you know just play hard like
no matter outcome play as hard as we can
and you know just continue to fight you
know to that last buzzer sound so
each and every game that's just how we
attack it
yeah cause i think during the playoffs
there were times people were like
counting you guys out we were always
like no we're going to come back we're
going to figure it out we're going to
always put up if i always give you a
good performance and you guys
definitely did that um
speaking of being counted out you talked
about it a bit the olympics
how you feel about the olympics uh right
now
um you know i'm happy those guys was
able to win that's big time
i actually watched that game yeah that
was the really the only game i've
watched you know i sent out tweets like
asking what was happening people thought
you know i was trying to be funny but i
really wasn't watching like i was trying
to figure out i just seen
us say this usa that and i'm like all
right so what's going on like
and it's like all right you know they
they lost this game they lost this game
and that's really
was the main topic when they were losing
mm-hmm it was game they was winning and
you just be like alright they won this
game and nobody said nothing else mm-hmm
like
i feel like that's just how it is now
but you know a lot of people was trying
to you know make it out like i was
trying to you know
diss the usa team and stuff but
it wasn't that like me i'ma speak my
mind i'm gonna tell you exactly how i
feel so
if i wanted to say something about him i
would have put the ad on there yeah at
usa you this i i would usa yeah like i
would
i wouldn't even sugarcoat it or try to
you know you know talk behind me back or
nothing like that yeah i was just really
trying to figure out you know what was
going on yeah for sure and i know you
were like really happy when when they
won and it was definitely a good game is
playing in the olympics a goal of yours
yeah for sure yeah it definitely is were
you like upset or hurt that it wasn't
this time around
uh nah not really i wouldn't i mean
i'm grateful and thankful for everything
i know like
it's all god's timing so
whenever my time comes you know i'll be
ready um i just you know took
you know this off season uh for a time
for me to you know uh just continue to
you know get better in all areas of my
game so
i wasn't you know too much pressed on
none of that yeah
so we're kind of in a moment in the nba
where
it's like a transition like the new
young guys are becoming the stars and
pretty soon older guys are gonna kind of
phase out is that what you feel right
now as someone in the league that this
is kind of like the new age yeah i feel
like you know it's
we have a lot of talent you know
anytime you mention you know guys under
25 there's you know a lot of guys you
can name exactly what i'm about to name
everybody right now because then they're
like oh you forgot this person but yeah
i feel like you know the league is in
very good hands you know with you know
the guys under 25 you know who
rising to be you know superstars in this
league what do you think is the
difference between a star and a
superstar i feel like you know you have
some guys you know who are you know
capable of being you know some of the
top players in this league it's just
certain little things like
superstars do you know
uh like if you mention like
kobe bryant like all those guys just
have you know like a
a different edge kd
i feel like you know they just
do what superstars do whether it's you
know taking on whatever challenge you
know bringing a team back
icing the game for their team you know
certain stuff like that not saying you
know it's
like you know some stars you know who
can't do it it's just
it's a difference yeah it's like this
thing you can't really put your finger
on but you just know it kind of when you
when you see it
this guy right here is a superstar like
you just know the difference yeah so
when we were talking about how you would
love to you know one day dunk on lebron
i like when people talk about you know
dunking on jordan who do you think of
this wave is gonna be that guy where
people talk about him as like almost the
standard i'm gonna say me i just have
that confidence in myself i knew you're
gonna say you i should have said he
can't say you
i said you're not allowed to do that
but i mean i think that
that's the thing so when someone asks
them a question like that and then they
say themselves everyone's like oh my god
they said themselves i can't believe
they would do that but why would you not
say yourself yeah
me personally i never say nobody
in this world
can beat me one-on-one better than me
like it's just that confidence i have in
myself
and no matter you know who i'm going up
against i'ma always take myself like i
i don't fear nobody so i mean everybody
you know like i've been saying put on
these shoes and stuff the same way i do
so yeah
there's no no point in you know being
scared of somebody out there
taking me and doubling down every time
yeah as you should as you should uh one
last thing i wanted to talk to you about
because we touched on it a bit um with
the article that i did with gq and i had
interviewed you for that very cute you
had your bottle of 42.
everybody that's josh's favorite drink
you ever want to give him anything
you had your 21st birthday in the bubble
in the bubble and like they threw a
little party for you
42 was on debt yeah 42
was a thing and then you very recently
turned 22. happy birthday i remember the
day
enjoy being enjoy being 22.
um but no in the bubble uh one thing you
were talking about was how really
difficult it was for you at times like
it was difficult for really most people
and you said that you went through a lot
of mental issues there but nobody really
knew
can you kind of elaborate on what it
looked like for you mentally uh me like
i'm a big family person so you know
being away from my family obviously you
know was tough on me anytime everybody
you know asked me like you know what's
your hobbies off the court like that's
my hobbies you know spending time with
my family we have found something to do
like no matter what like here we all
just started just playing mad just
to you know just bond like we just sit
outside
play the game
and you know it was just very
competitive but you know being in that
bubble you know i wasn't able to do that
i had to talk to you know all my family
you know through facetime which was you
know
it's not a bad thing but it was tough
you know not actually seeing them i had
a daughter couldn't even see her trying
to talk to her through facetime and
i don't know i just felt like the the
bubble just wasn't me like obviously
like i'm
i'm a homebody like i like being home
but
you know just being stuck in there and
not being able to do nothing was you
know kind of tough like
i was just
overthinking a lot like i was you know
getting down like
but i don't i don't tell nobody you know
none of that stuff like i just
anytime somebody asked me like
like are you okay i'm i always say you
know i'm good even if i'm not like i'm
just kind of used to you know getting
through stuff on my own so
it was
definitely tough for me so yeah
not saying i was ready to leave the
bubble but i was yeah right i mean
everyone else everyone was ready to go
but i mean is that difficult like to
know that even if you're not okay you're
saying you are and it's like okay well
when you're not okay what do you do you
talk to like what if it feels like it's
not it's not i feel like
you know the word now people say it's
toxic i feel like it is like because
it can go either way like you know you
probably can get through it or you can
go down even more um
i always said like like one of my uh
favorite quotes was you don't realize
you're drowning when you're trying to be
everyone else's anchor
so like through the bubble like i was
you know just thinking about that quote
like you know sometimes you gotta you
know put yourself first like your health
no matter what it is like
i'm always making sure everybody else
straight but sometimes i gotta you know
worry about me and normally that's the
times you know when i
you know
be in a dark place when i'm
trying to make sure everybody else good
knowing i'm not good and just be even
more you know harder so yeah that's one
of the things i felt like
they tried to do well in the bubble was
you know how when you would wake up
you'd have to do the questionnaire and
like the very last question they say is
like do you want to speak to a mental
health professional today yeah and i
thought that was like a really nice
thing that they did because it was hard
for so many people and
when i've done interviews i talked about
it i talked to jimmy butler about
therapy i just talked to michael jordan
about therapy and they all said like i
have tried this and it has helped me
michael b said that he still does it is
that something that you would try i
think you know eventually i would um
normally like i'm just so used to
either getting through it myself or just
talking to my fam right or like my you
know my close people like i don't trust
a lot of people you know with
with certain stuff so i feel like that's
why i haven't yet but i mean right now i
feel like you know
my life is good like totally i'm happy
i'm enjoying it just gotta stay right
there yes no that's what i say you
always have a smile on your face yeah
yeah always smiling it's a lot behind
the smile but right now it's all smiles
good no i'm glad because like i guess
you know everybody always be like she
only wouldn't talk about jaws doing well
i'm like yeah i do
he's my favorite uh but no so i'm so
happy you were able to come on and do
this but tell me like what what's the
biggest jump you're gonna make next
season what are we gonna see from draw
i'm trying to be an all-star
all-nba team and i'm trying to win a
championship
that's my three goals right there so we
get and then maybe with some tweaks
when the dunk contest
we'll see we'll see
stay tuned
but no thanks for your time you're
fantastic as always hair has grown
exponentially since the first time i met
you get it done i look rough on camera
right now
i hope y'all can do you know put a
little filter or something on me a
little photoshop yeah
you got me
you got me all right
thank you no problem
[Music]